so most of what we do on all these
platforms me personally is we're taking
YouTube content so we're making the long
form videos and then we cut it up you
take the best moments and you turn them
into all of these different platforms
you can do it yourself through editing
or you can hire somebody whether it's
somebody who's local whether it's
somebody on Fiverr whether it's somebody
who's in your community who you're doing
an exchange of services you're coaching
them and they're helping you with
content this doesn't have to be heavily
edited it doesn't have to be highly
skilled again like focused on the
quality of thought more than the
production quality and then again like
let's make it lead to business so that
leads to lead magnet it's not just
creating content into a void we want to
lead them to a lead magnet and then
that's where the selling is done so
we're not making sales videos that go up
on YouTube Instagram Etc like I might
make a post on when momentum comes out
my book right I might make a post to say
hey momentum came out go check it out
but it won't get nearly as much reach
because it's a sales pitch so if all
your videos are just sales pitches it's
Dead on Arrival nobody's gonna watch it
whether it's YouTube Instagram Tick Tock
it doesn't matter so we want people to
get to know us love us want to connect
with us to get their email address and
then we're giving them value emails and
then we're selling them
creating unique and consist
ENT plot platforms so thought leadership
success map this is the Holy Grail this
is the whole thing all in one Graphics
if you're ever struggling like how do I
make content and how do I dive deeper
into the content I'm making this this is
this is the Holy Grail right here so
we've talked about this in the past but
I haven't brought it up in a while and
so this is what we want to be focused on
at the Top This is a top-down approach
it's like how do you be on every
platform
back to the initial topic that we're
talking about today like how do we be on
every platform while still running our
business and still not being like a
full-time influencer in all these places
right at the top it's our 10 minute
videos
and that's YouTube and Instagram lives
it's long form content that then gets
broken down and one of the things that
I've been working with a lot on with
people whether it's movie makers on our
live sessions or some big name people
that I'm that I'm working with and
helping them grow their channels
I think we're overlooking this section
here on the left a lot
what do you want to try to get business
from so yesterday I did an IG live with
Erica Lane who's who's a movement maker
who's been with us for sign up for the
year
um it's like well what do you what do
you want to make money at what are you
trying to sell what are you trying to
create and for her it's leadership so
she sells leadership into corporations
but she also wants a little Downstream
to help leaders who are just getting
started like entrepreneurs who are
building their businesses up but now
we're leading and potentially down into
self-leadership like what does it mean
to lead yourself or to lead your family
or to lead little Community groups but
like whatever you want to try to make
money doing show me the show me the
process of you doing it this is the
fastest way to start not just making
content but also having a turn into
business for you so for Erica we're
creating her her plan yesterday
in her five videos that she was gonna
make
two were going to be targeting the
corporate because that's where she makes
money that's the easiest way for her to
make money right now she has a she has a
process she can if somebody comes in
from corporate she knows how to how to
sell them train them give them a lot of
value so two just towards them two
towards the the entrepreneurs that are
25 employee plus is her kind of
threshold for who she wants to work with
cool and she can help them and then one
towards the experimental self-leadership
family leadership kind of stuff because
she doesn't really know she doesn't have
a business model built out around that
yet
and so I want you guys yes making
content but the more we can turn it into
business faster the easier it is to keep
going right because now we're making
some money doing it so what do you
ultimately want to sell what's your
business model what are we trying to
create who are we trying to serve and
then making content geared specifically
towards them is the easiest type to get
started it's the most fun and it leads
to revenue which allows you to continue
to build up and grow so whether it's
thought leadership which is direct to
camera stuff
coaching your your coaching clients but
it's going to be on a video mentoring is
now that that's going to be a series
you're mentioning someone on your team
you're doing interviews with people q a
Biz Dev is is massively overlooked so if
you're looking at doing
think about who could be a partner for
you and your business in built the
server I talk about the three ways to
grow your business right does the fast
passive Freedom where you're doing the
Outreach and you're direct messaging
people and trying to connect with them
and it's it's basically sales right but
through social media
second one is Partnerships where you're
thinking who can I partner with that if
they knew who I was and they were
recommending me it would lead to
tremendous business for me and then the
third is thought leadership where you're
creating content on on YouTube Instagram
Tick Tock Etc but in the Partnerships we
can combine them so who's a good
potential partner for your business
and instead of just messaging them and
say hey do you want to have a coffee or
can I introduce you to my company what
I'm doing invite them as a guest on your
show
and we don't even care about how many
views that video gets necessarily it's
more about the relationship that you're
going to build
because they may not spend the time with
you to meet over coffee or take a sales
call but they love telling their store
and they love being on shows
so you use your show Even if you have a
tiny Channel you ask them to be a guest
on your show and that builds the
relationship because you're going to
spend time with them they're gonna
they're gonna get to know you like you
trust you right they're gonna love you
and they're going to ask what do you do
what's your what's your deal what are
you all about which thing gives you the
chance to talk about your business
and a lot of great Partnerships will end
up happening as results so people
definitely Overlook the biz Dev part and
then the document is going to be you're
showing the behind the scenes of your
life of your business that's usually the
hardest one to make takes the most
editing which I'm I'm not a big fan of
at the beginning when you're starting on
your journey but this is the top-down
approach right it's like our 10 minute
plus videos we're going long form and
this may be all you need to create
Terrell says just landed a partnership
doing this yeah it's honestly a great
challenge for you guys
for this month is think about three
people that if they knew who you were
three companies or people that they knew
who you were and they were talking about
you would make a meaningful difference
to Growing your business
and then reach out to them and invite
them to be a guest on your new show even
if it's a brand new show
reach out to them and be a guest on your
show so you built a relationship from
there we we take the best moments and
turn into micro content so most of what
we do on all these platforms me
personally is we're taking YouTube
content so we're making the long form
videos and then we cut it up
you take the best moments and you turn
them into all of these different
platforms
you can do it yourself through editing
or you can you can hire somebody whether
it's somebody who's local whether it's
somebody on Fiverr whether it's somebody
who's in your community who you're doing
an exchange of services you're coaching
them and they're helping you with
content
this is not
doesn't have to be heavily edited it
doesn't have to be highly skilled again
like focus on the quality of thought
more than the production quality Wendy
says sending out invites today let's go
Wendy that's what I'm talking about
uh and then and then again like let's
make it lead to business so that leads
to a lead magnet it's not just creating
content into a void we want to lead them
to a lead magnet so we had
um Erica who was on with me yesterday on
Instagram
uh her Instagram bio link wasn't working
right it's like okay well that's the
first thing we need to pick so when I
click on your link it actually goes to
your website but ideally it leads to a
lead magnet so we can capture their
email addresses and then that's where
the selling is done so we're not making
sales videos that go up on YouTube
Instagram Etc
if you make a video it's it's not the
end of the world like I might make a
post on when momentum comes out my book
right I might make a post to say hey
momentum came out go check it out but it
won't get nearly as much reach because
it's it's a sales pitch
so if all your videos are just sales
pitches it's Dead on Arrival nobody's
gonna watch it whether it's YouTube
Instagram Tick Tock it doesn't matter
so we want people to get to know us love
us want to connect with us to get their
email address and then we're giving them
value emails and then we're selling them
right and selling them it
I guess it has a negative connotation
it's like we're giving them value we're
providing our service we're helping them
and then whatever you're trying to sell
right these are some examples
so this is still the model that I use
this is still the model I recommend
using you could have strategies for each
of these individual platforms
uh uh it can just become overwhelming
but I don't want you to get overwhelmed
and feel like it's impossible and then
nothing happens and we don't stay
consistent Brian is saying I should
probably stick with the past faster
freedom for now right so
the three models and built the serve
fast passive Freedom which is the direct
messaging Outreach Partnerships and then
content those are the three models
it all depends on on how quickly you
need to bring in business like if you
need to bring in business right away
then it's sales it's Outreach it's
direct messaging people it's it's
one-on-one connections and you're
sending 15 100 messages a day connecting
with people and some people will pick
that up if I if I really want it I need
to sell movement makers or I need to
sell momentum like the easiest thing to
me to do maybe not the easiest the most
effective short-term thing today would
be start messaging everybody
like anybody who follows me anybody
who's got a an issue with momentum
anybody posting around how they're stuck
or they're they're not in momentum mode
they're procrastinating they're
overthinking direct messaging and some
people will pick it up
it's a lot of grunt work but it's the
fastest way to bring in deals the
partnership is really slow and then it
goes really fast so if one is going to
do the Outreach and send three three
messages today there's that's slow
you're building a relationship but once
you get the right relationship they say
yes then it can go really fast because
that one person can can send you ten a
hundred a thousand client sales Etc and
then the content is the slowest but it's
the most effective long term
so that the videos that you make now
they may not get a result right now but
in a month and in two months and six
months and 12 months and 24 months the
videos are still there still driving
leads attention interest awareness for
what you're doing so it just depends on
how quickly you need to make things
happen
today what I'm going to talk about
is how to choose and create an online
product or service that can be scaled
and sold digitally super important uh
you are thought leader you're an expert
you have wisdom to share and being able
to monetize your ideas your wisdom is
important because if you're not making
money
then you have a side hobby not a real
business is going to have a big impact
so one of the things that I cover in
build to serve is what I call the recipe
for success and you see BTS are on the
screen because that means built to serve
so there's there's
a couple questions that I asked that if
you can figure this out it's then a
recipe that you can teach other people
so you think about how did you save
yourself so you're built to serve you
want to help other people who are
currently going through the same thing
that you went through right so you know
think about who you were five or ten
years ago that person what they're
struggling with right you're going back
and talking to yourself that's going to
be your ultimate purpose and now we need
to figure out a way to monetize that so
you can do that and have a bigger reach
so how did you save yourself
how did you get out of the hole that you
were in
and it may not have been a super clear
path right maybe you tried a whole bunch
of different things
and some of them didn't work most of
them probably didn't work and and for a
lot of us whatever hole you were in I
remember me being an entrepreneur I love
helping entrepreneurs because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur I
struggled and tried so many different
things I felt like I had all these
different ideas and I tried them all and
nothing worked and I failed and I failed
and I failed and I failed until I found
the thing that actually worked which was
modeling success looking at Bill Gates
and how he started Microsoft I copied
that that idea of Partnerships Microsoft
built their business through
Partnerships
their big deal came with IBM where every
IBM computer ship had Microsoft software
on it and Microsoft is already a seven
million dollar company when that
happened
so how did they get the seven million
same thing through Partnerships I
started applying Partnerships to my
business and suddenly had my first check
for thirteen and a half thousand dollars
which was mind-blowing to me which I'm
making 300 bucks a month so 13 and a
half K was huge and then they gave me a
recipe they could do again and again and
again and again so I I tried so many
things I felt like I tried everything I
tried everything in my head right and
nothing was working until finally the
partnership strategy came through by
modeling Bill Gates and and that helped
explode my business forward what have I
done since
it's just more modeling success right I
mean that was back when I was 19. so
it's been 20 years of just modeling
success and trying to help now other
entrepreneurs model success right if you
look at my channel and the content it's
me sharing my ideas and modeling what
other people are doing and so I tried a
whole bunch of stuff most of it didn't
work and then finally here's this one
thing that worked I went hardcore at it
and that's what I've been teaching for
the past 20 years so same thing for you
you went through
a really tough time you went through
massive challenges you never want to go
back to that really painful moment and
you know there's so many people who
currently are in that most painful
moment you've tried so many things right
you used to try so many things most of
the things didn't work out but finally
you hit on one two or three things that
actually worked that started working for
you that is then when you can teach
other people
to help them shortcut the path right
you're a mentor you're a teacher you're
a guide now right you've you may not
have totally come out on the other side
but you're ahead of where you used to be
and so that's your opportunity to say
I've been through what you're going
through I've tried all those things that
you're trying and didn't work but here
is the one that actually opened up the
gates for me this is the one thing that
when you figure this out can explode
your whole growth forward
so for me it was my own success for you
what was it and so the question of how
did you save yourself and sometimes it's
difficult because we don't want to think
back to the negative and what you know
where we're in our really low points but
you have to not the point to live there
but
the point of being able to go back and
save yourself and other people like you
so how did you save yourself so step one
recipe for Success ask yourself these
three questions one one you to decide
that something had to change so if I
look at my story I struggled as an
entrepreneur
and and nothing was working and I'm
making 300 bucks a month and I was too
embarrassed to tell my friends that I
wasn't working out
and I just kept trying trying trying it
was when I told my business partner that
I quit
one night on a on a you know
Thanksgiving or some kind of family
holiday and I I told my partner I quit I
can't do this anymore I need to I need
to feel like a worthwhile human being
the next day I woke up and said I can't
quit I just have to find a different way
to stand because I'm going to regret it
if I quit right now because I haven't
given everything I've got and that
opened me up to thinking I can't be the
first person to have gone through this
like somebody else has done it and
that's what led me to Bill Gates because
he's built the software company he's the
only guy I could think of who built a
software company I was in software uh
and so that's when it had to change
that's when I decided something had to
change that the way that I'm going can't
continue to go as it is right now
something has to change so for you and
your life when did you decide that it
had to change you were probably in that
painful situation for months or years or
for for some people a decade you you've
struggled for so long and then boom this
marking point that said now this has the
change right connecting to that and
write that down like when was the moment
that you decided that it had to change
for you because when you can identify
that moment for you you can then give it
and gift it to other people to help them
have their moment as well because until
they decide that it has to change
nothing's going to happen you can give
them the best answers the best
strategies what you know works but
they're not going to do it because they
haven't decided to change
so it starts with you sharing your story
of when you decided that it had to
change for you and and maybe you know it
maybe you have to dig deep and find it a
lot of this worked for me I had to dig
back and find it because I'm naturally
one I don't think backwards and I don't
I don't especially negative thoughts
going backwards I live in the present
and the future so it took me some work
to find it maybe you know absolutely
where it is right for you right now but
um do the work to figure out when did
you decide that this had to be a must
that you wanted to change so the next
part of that is
what was the first thing that you did to
start the change
what was the first thing that you did
when you decided that you had to change
what was the next step that you took
because this is something we're now
going to teach to other people you're
going to help them decide that they have
to change and then you have to give them
the first easy step for them to start
making progress so for me I was alone I
did it by myself chances are for you you
are alone you did it by yourself you're
going to help it be easy for other
people because now they've got you
they've got a guide they've got a mentor
they've got a sage they've got somebody
to lead them down the path
so for me it was thinking
who has done this before I can't be the
first person to do it I looked at Bill
Gates and I started researching his
story what was the very first thing that
you did
after you decided
because once somebody decides we have to
get the momentum this is now going to be
your job how do you help somebody one
decide and then two get momentum it may
not be anywhere close to them hitting
the final goal right just thinking about
Bill Gates doesn't mean I'm going to
build a successful software company
but the process of getting started of
building momentum is the biggest thing
that most people are just missing they
haven't decided and then they have no
momentum so what's the very first thing
that they need to do to give them
momentum and what's amazing about you
guys is you
are guiding them and giving them hope
where chances are for you there was
nobody helping you out
so with your hope with your advice with
you saying I've been through this you
can make it through this as well your
belief in them gives them belief in
themselves you got through there's a lot
of people who never make it through
whatever you struggled with there's a
lot of people who never actually get on
the other side we've decided to change
we figured what our first thing was to
make the change and then how did you
sustain the momentum so
it's amazing that you did that first
step
what did you then do every day to
sustain that momentum because so many
people have these Great Moments and then
they relapse right you've got these
Great Moments and then you stop saying
consistent you fall apart it goes away
so
what did you do did you did you put it
in your calendar did you get an
accountability partner did you read a
book every day like what was the thing
that helped you sustain the energy and
momentum so that it wasn't just this
one-off moment of boldness one one-off
moment of greatness and then you fell
back down right and so for me I
dedicated myself every day to learning
from some successful entrepreneur
I picked up a book called radicals and
Visionaries that is out of print it's
not honestly that great a book but
it is basically what my YouTube channel
became where it showed a famous
entrepreneur and their story in three to
four pages and every day I would wake up
and just read a story from that book
three to four pages right super easy one
it got me motivated and two gave me
ideas of what I could do to continue to
help build my business and so that's
what I would do every morning is try to
be around some other successful
entrepreneur YouTube wasn't around 20
years ago so I didn't I didn't have that
to to be able to help me otherwise it
would be all in on watching a video
every single morning
but for you what was the thing how did
you sustain the momentum every day to
now get you out of the hall and doesn't
mean you were perfect maybe you had some
low moments on your climb up but you're
climbing You're Building you're moving
so this process that you went through
is your recipe for success and it's
teachable
this is the whole point of this this is
teachable your path out may have taken
you 10 years to get to where you are but
you can condense it down and teach it to
other people
that's how you build your movement
that's how you start getting paid that's
how you start making an impact on the
people that you want to make an impact
right so we're condensing your 10-year
journey into
a week a month six months however long
it's actually going to take people to do
but massively condense down from X
number of years for you to get here
because you failed and you struggled and
you had no coach or Mentor you're going
to give them the path and you're going
to coach and Mentor them so they can get
there much faster and maybe save their
life for some of you I know your story I
know where you came from you're actually
dealing with life or death situations
for me it was just entrepreneurship I
felt low as a human I was never suicidal
you know depressed I was never anywhere
close to be on the edge of you know
ending my life or anything
life-threatening but for some of you
guys like that's real
um and I've heard your stories I don't
know all your stories here in the group
but I've heard some of your stories and
what you could do could actually save
people's lives
um and so I'm really pumped for for you
to get this out there
we got an important topic to talk about
today how to accelerate the growth of
your movement I'm excited let's dive
into it so the fast passive Freedom this
is again inbuilt to serve
you want to think about the social media
accounts where you're going to live on
and so you think about Instagram you
think about LinkedIn think about Twitter
YouTube uh Facebook right you think
about your main social media accounts
you start by having just the account you
create a professional picture bio and
content right in all of any social media
Network you're going to have the option
to add a picture bio and content and now
gear your picture and your bio towards
your ideal customer what I want you
thinking of if my ideal customer landed
on my page if you're looking at
Instagram right if your ideal client
landed on your Instagram page what they
want to call you what they want to work
with you what they want to potentially
hire you is there enough on there that
makes you think this person knows what
they're talking about they are the
expert they can help me I need to reach
out right so this is what we want to be
doing across all of our social accounts
what's the picture you're going to use
what's your bio that you're going to add
and what content you're going to put up
a lot of times there's inconsistencies
across different platforms there's no
real thought or care consideration to it
make a picture that's a headshot I want
you zoomed in not a full body shot
unless you're in Fitness
maybe there's a case right to see the
whole body but even then people resonate
with the face I want people to recognize
you instantly and so have the same
picture across all your social media
accounts
uh and then again a buyer that speaks to
to your ideal client my my idea is I
want people to come look at your account
and then say I want to work with this
person next we're going to create 10
pieces of content and that's it so what
do you actually make the 10 pieces of
I laid out in in the book we'll go over
super quickly here it starts with number
one your who right so what's your most
important core value why tell me where
it comes from tell me why it's so
important to you show me why you care
like this is this is how you stand out
versus most people most people's
accounts are boring most companies
accounts are super boring most people
are saying the exact same thing and so
don't make it look like a resume you're
who it's your most important core value
if I'm making a a post about believe it
should it should ooze
confidence and and energy and
awesomeness right and from the heart so
what is your most important core value
and then make an emotional piece of
content that could be a video or could
be written form just something that if I
read it I'm gonna feel that same thing
I'm gonna feel Believe by reading your
belief post two is explain your why so
tell me why you're doing what you're
doing tell me your pain that you went
through and tell me how it led to your
purpose right all the stuff that we're
talking about in the book
talk to me about your darkest moment and
how you came out of it
people don't want to learn from the
perfect person people don't want to
learn from the person who looks like
they have it all figured out because it
makes people feel like well they're
perfect I can't be like that I need to
know that you went through the same
thing I went through
that is the thing that will make people
connect to you and so I need to see a
post talking about your why right and
this this format
can be it could be nine YouTube or ten
YouTube videos it could be 10 Instagram
posts 10 LinkedIn posts 10 tweets right
I just need to have content there so
it's not a debt account with just a face
and a bio
and then three is give me your how give
me an overview of your recipe for
success we talk about in the book where
basically how did you get out of the
problem that you were in and how can you
then use that as a tool to teach other
people how they can get out of it as
well that should be one post one of the
things that a lot of people struggle
with when they're creating content is
they're all over the map you wanna you
have so much in your head and you want
to say so many things but then when you
look at a post it's it's a mix of 18
different messages tighten it down Focus
one key thought per post make me feel
one thing if you make me feel ten things
I don't know what to do next right one
key thing per post so you're who your
why your how are three or the 10 codes I
want to see in your Mason 10 pack of
content treat it like you're brochure
this is your brochure this is your flyer
this is you talking about what you're
doing and showcasing that you are an
expert because if I'm coming to your
page your profile with a problem one
that you know that you can solve I need
to feel like you are the person to help
me four to six is your recipe breakdown
so how you got out of it
teach me
so the first three posts are more
inspiring more motivational more you
understand me you know what I'm going
through because you've been through it
as well right it connects with me on a
human level your next three are now
going to be you teaching me something
so specifically what did you do or what
can I do to help me get out of the
problem that you know how to solve
and that's three different posts if you
can mix it up between if I'm taking
Instagram if you make it up between
pictures videos fire captions awesome
same thing for LinkedIn
pictures videos fire caption if you're
doing Pinterest you have an amazing
picture but write some awesome caption
step 7 is results I want to see your
results I want to see uh your client
results of people who you've helped show
me their results so now if you think
about this Arc of a story we're telling
our first three are these emotional
pieces that makes me connect to you as a
human our next three is telling me
exactly what I need to do to get out of
the hole that I'm in right step by step
and don't worry like nobody's gonna take
that thing and just run with it and
crush it people are afraid to give up
their secrets you need to Showcase that
you are an expert and you know what
you're talking about so don't be afraid
about giving them a high level step one
do this and then results so you're
showing me
uh what happened tell me again your
story somebody else's story we're taking
people on a journey on an arc so that
we're likely way more likely to convert
people to want to hire us want to work
with us eight nine now show me more
examples so showing me again more
specifics take me on a journey of of you
or people you've helped dive deeper if
you haven't helped anybody yet give me a
hypothetical example right show me who
you would be helping uh hypothetical of
a mom who has you know these scenarios
or a dad like this or an entrepreneur
just starting off right
um I could if it were me and I was just
getting started it'd be a story about
entrepreneurs who are trying to get
their first business off the off the
ground if you look at books like the go
Giver
um Bob berg a friend of the channel it's
it's a parable right they're teaching
through
uh a narrative that doesn't actually
exist it's not a real character but
you're learning through those stories so
what is a story if you don't have any
actual examples or clients you can share
and then your last point is is Hope
give me hope make me feel hope uh make
me feel like it's possible make me feel
like I'm not alone make me feel like
where I'm at right now doesn't have to
be where I'm going to finish uh it makes
a huge huge huge difference because if
you've now taken me on this journey of
you've connected with me emotionally
you've you've shown me that you know
what you're talking about and that I can
get through it you've shown me examples
and results of other people who've done
it and you've done it as well and then
you leave with an inspirational message
of hope that that it's possible for me
as well you're giving people an arc that
if people are going through these 10
posts they're way more likely to want to
work with you and so this can help as a
structure give you Clarity over the
content to create for your accounts and
I would apply this for all of my
accounts I would apply this for every
single platform that you create an
account on and then stop the goal here
is not to be the thought leader content
producer making making pieces of content
every single day getting out there this
is the fast pass to Freedom this this is
now we're going to start to doing
Outreach the goal here is I want if
people come to your account to see you
as the expert next step is how do I get
people to come to my account but you got
to give them something on your account
that makes you seem credible and I want
to work with you hire you contact you
take the next step with you right it's
worth spending time on all of these uh
normally when I'm when I'm talking about
making content on the thought leadership
side I say don't worry so much about
production quality don't worry about
having the perfect words each time just
get it out there these ones it's worth
treated like a marketing brochure it's
worth spend a little bit more time on
not necessarily from having a camera
crew come in and film you and making it
perfect but even from the end of just
you being prepared you not just throwing
up your first take you really spending
time on each to go over it because this
is now going to do all the heavy lifting
for us once we get people coming to our
page so how do we actually get people to
see our account
you reach out and there's two key ways
search and hashtags and depending on the
platform you're looking at uh some you
can search just for keywords if you go
to YouTube you can Search keywords you
can see what people are going through uh
hashtags are almost on every platform
Instagram you can't search you can only
go through hashtags or your searching is
through hashtags and you're looking for
people who are struggling with the thing
that you struggled with right your
purpose comes to your pain the people
who are going to help are the people who
currently are who you used to be the
great thing about social media is that
people are sharing all the time people
are sharing what they're going through
they're sharing what they're struggling
with they're sharing what they what
their inner demons are they're sharing
they're sharing this so you're looking
for the people who are talking about the
thing that you can help with for example
in in the book I talk about uh a guy
named Michael who helped me overcome my
concussion and we created a template for
him to say hey look for people who are
talking about concussions on Instagram
look at people who are posting because
when you get a concussion a lot of
people with the news they're going to
post Instagram
and most of the time people are just
posting to to get support from their
friends uh and sometimes to complain
right but if you're there reaching out
for help
you're saying hey I know what you're
going through I've been through that
myself I want to help I've got ideas for
you that might be able to help you what
are they going to do next
is that how that's interesting this is
the only person reaching out to me uh
they're gonna go check out your account
what are they going to say in your
account they're going to see an amazing
picture an amazing bio and 10 pieces of
amazing content that we just spent all
this time working on right so the idea
is every day we're going to reach out to
people every day we're going to reach
out to people we're going to send DMS
we're gonna we're gonna text them we're
gonna send them messages
offering hope
offering guidance offering uh what I
like to do is offer a call so what I
recommend is offering a free call with
people
and guide them through how you can help
and give them value on the call like
your point of a free call is they want
to come back and work with you again
they want to they should be asking how
much does it cost to hire you okay can I
can I bring you on as my coach can I
continue working with you somehow if
you're not getting that after a free
call then you didn't do a good enough
job on the call yet in terms of
providing value and so you keep
practicing right you keep practicing
doing more and more free calls we have
our picture we have our link we have our
bio we have our 10 pieces of content and
we stop posting content and just start
outreaching
this is the fastest way to start getting
clients to start building your business
influence and persuasion so number one
is coaching and wearing their skin it's
super valuable I like to say that I wear
people's skin I think if you're a great
coach you wear people's skin where
you're telling them what they should do
versus what you would do this is a this
is a big separation that a lot of people
don't get yes you have been through it
and yes you have your recipe for Success
that can help them but the exact step
they may need next may not be the one
that you exactly did and so the more you
can think what does this person in front
of me right now need versus what you
would do in their situation makes you a
better coach
and I'll often give advice that I would
never do myself
um it also means that I uh I'll often
talk like people so I remember I coached
a mentored lily to help her build a
coaching practice and she had this one
session we had where she was frustrated
and upset and and was swearing a lot and
so I started swearing back to her and
she said I've never heard you swear
before like I'm not I'm you
right I think that I think the best
coach
for you to be the best coach is for you
to be and reflect back the best version
of the person that you're talking to
so when I was swearing back at Lily it
wasn't me talking it was the better Lily
I had a twitch session last night
um where uh a guy came on and he said
the trust your gut and like yes trust
your gut I am your gut I told him I am
your gut I was reflecting back what I
needed to hear the best version of him
again not necessarily what I would do
but what he needs to do
uh so you're wearing their skin it's not
just trying to be like them it's being
them you become the best version of them
so as you get more practice uh you'll
discover pattern recognition you'll see
the same things happening over and over
and over and over again and that'll help
lead you to faster steps so you know you
see where they are right now you know
they can get here but you don't quite
know the steps to take them through the
more you do it the more you'll say oh
this person's like that person who I
helped last week and and yesterday and
last month and you can go faster Through
the Motions always listening to your own
gut and then using the 85 rule this is
from build to serve uh page 240 where
you are when you're 85 sure you're 100
sure
you're asked questions until you get to
85 then once you get to 85 you go into
coaching mode so
the first part about influence and
persuasion is being the best version of
them because they don't want to listen
to you but they want to listen to them
and so
a lot of people if they don't like what
I'm saying it's because they don't like
themselves I'm just reflecting
themselves back
uh and a lot of times if you jump into a
coaching session this is why it's
sometimes hard for the Instagram stuff
that I put up of coaching people a lot
of times it can come off as really harsh
if you watch some of my sessions with
people you can see how harsh sometimes I
am I am on them
um and it's meant not for the audience
this is where I get into a fight with my
agent sometimes because he's like design
a show for the audience it's not meant
for the audience it's meant for that
person I want that person to get a
result
and we're we're jumping steps even if
the audience can't understand it
and so sometimes I come off of super
soft and sometimes super hard and
sometimes pushy and sometimes will swear
and sometimes whatever because what that
person needs to get the results so try
to get out of your own way try to get
out of what you would do and step into
their shoes and say what should they do
versus what I would do okay so this is
the 85 rule explained it's in the book
basically when you're 85 sure then you
then you are a hundred
you act like you're 100 but you become a
hundred because when you have confidence
in something that confidence leads for
the other person to have confidence
if you're 85 sure
and listen there's always going to be
some doubt because you don't actually
know this person you're coaching and
helping right there's always going to be
some level of Doubt but if you have any
doubt when you're giving them advice
they're afraid of the advice in the
first place they're afraid to make the
change and so they don't want to make
the change and they're going to hang on
to the doubt
even though you're 85 sure or 90 sure if
you allow for a hedge if you allow for a
little bit of doubt
they're going to hang on to that doubt
and then not take action
and that was a mistake I made earlier on
going through this process of coaching
and helping people is that I would give
options I would hedge because I would
tell myself I don't really know this
person and so there could always be some
exception
but to assume that the person in front
of you is the exception when you're 85
sure is actually cheating them the
opportunity to grow
and so when you're 85 sure you become
100 sure and your confidence in them
allows them to have confidence in
themselves
your confidence and their ability
because you're absolutely certain that
they can do this thing this is the path
you can't accomplish this you can make
that song or write that book or break up
with that person or whatever the next
step is that they need to do you're 100
absolute confidence in their ability to
do this thing
is stronger then their lack of
confidence in the thing right whoever is
more confident wins and so if you are
more confident in them than they are not
confident in themselves you win and they
become more confident in themselves
that's why you have to get the 100 so
how do you do this
you go question question question
question question question
just keep asking questions you get to 85
sure and then you coach and if you watch
my videos
when I'm helping somebody
you'll see that
they take this this similar Arc where
it's non-stop just with no judgment
asking them questions you're making them
feel safe you're giving them an
opportunity to share but you're not
putting them on the defensive
this is where a lot of new coaches mess
up
you're asking questions with an answer
already in mind and you're judging them
which puts them on the defensive a lot
of times when you're asking the
questions
it can be seen as judgmental it can put
them on the defensive you're you're
raising their walls which then becomes
really hard to push them forward
and so it's super important that all
you're doing in the questions is seeking
to understand I'm just trying to
understand all you're doing is asking
questions
understanding them until in your own
head you're coming up with this is what
the person needs to do
you get the 85 certainty and then it's
like a switch if you watch my videos of
coaching it's a switch
it shuts from just asking questions say
this is what you need to do I have
peeked into your soul
I'm wearing your skin
I'm 85 sure that means I'm a hundred
this is what you need to do
and now we're into coaching mode and
it's through the
the question asking in a non-judgmental
tone that you get the information that
you need
now sometimes you may not get to
an answer sometimes you may not know
what to do for them you may not know how
to help and this is where new coaches
really struggle because you're always
you're in Fix-It mode right you want to
help people always you want to help help
and and you tie yourself forth to
helping and if you don't help them get a
result then you feel worse about
yourself
understand that listen alone is value
you might be the only person who's ever
actually listened to this person
whatever they're struggling to deal with
you might be the only one who is there
for them who's who they can have a
conversation with like maybe the things
they're telling you they haven't told
their partner they haven't told their
parents they haven't told their friends
they haven't told their kids they
haven't told anybody that alone is value
even if you don't get to a solution of
what they should do next that alone is
value I mean think about Alex from
Toronto Dan salsa he's he's going
through this process with me uh even
this morning was messaging me helping
coach somebody else on our team at TDS
and
some of the mistakes that he's made in
his in his passion to want to go off and
help people is rush into a judgment is
asking questions that again put people
on the defensive and then they push him
away and don't want to talk to him
they they say oh here comes another
session because if you're pushing people
on the wrong thing you lose credibility
you lose respect you lose your ability
to influence and persuade so you have to
make sure that the thing that you're
pushing on is the thing that they need
exact help with and if you can't get
there it's okay listen alone is value
and through the pattern recognition and
repeat you'll get better at it so this
is what I told Alex to do to get better
Omegle is a place for people to chat
with strangers so I told Alex you have
to go on and chat with strangers
he's trying to spread belong he's trying
to help people uh and push them like
many of you to be the best version of
themselves he does it through his own
way and so go on go on Omegle
uh choose the video option and start
helping people listen to them and start
helping them so you get you get more of
a rapid turnaround on being able to get
the practice in because you may not be
doing chances are you're not doing
enough coaching right now you're not
doing enough helping right now you're
not doing enough of these things if
you're doing it once every two weeks
you're just not going to get good enough
right like do anything once every two
weeks you don't you don't develop the
the skill set fast enough right Michael
Jordan wasn't
shooting basketball once every two weeks
if you want to be the Michael Jordan of
this you need to practice practice so I
told them to go on Amigo and he's been
posting some of his videos onto YouTube
where you just chat with strangers and
people rotate through and you get it's
based off of interest and uh you get
some people come on and you just have a
conversation
and so you get to rapidly like you could
today go through 10 different people and
just practice practice practice your
listening practice your understanding
practice your questioning practice your
ability to get to 85 percent uh practice
your then coaching to help them get a
result that they want
today we're going to talk about how to
find where my 1000 true fans are hiding
it's a good topic
um when I saw it pop up I was pumped
yesterday to uh start diving into some
thoughts I love the polling system we
created I really love it I love that you
guys are giving feedback on what you
want to talk about and we're pulling
some of the things from the book but
then also what I really love about this
group is I can share my my current best
practices like what am I doing exactly
right now so a lot of the examples I'm
going to share are just what I was doing
yesterday you know when you write a book
you want it to last right so you can't
always share exactly what you're doing
right now because it's going to change
in six months it's going to change in a
year it's going to change in five years
right I want people in 10 years to still
read this book and find it valuable but
the the value of this group is you get
you get the access to exactly right now
what I'm working on so it's always so
much fun putting these together for you
so let's dive in so how to find where my
1000 true fans are hiding
as always giving a shout out to who came
up with this topic Mr Ben McNeil I'm of
Ben's in the house I was in the house
yet I haven't seen you Ben if you're in
the house say hi walk aboard thank you
for the awesome topic so how to find
where my 1 000 true fans are hiding so
number one they're not hiding you are
when I first saw this topic I was
excited but also a little a little tiny
bit put off just in the warning because
I want you guys to always take 100
accountability Right This is How I Live
it's my fault it's my responsibility to
get out there and make the progress that
I want and the beginning is great right
how to how to seeking answers you're
looking you're searching you're trying
to find it but that last part of hiding
they're not hiding right that's putting
that's putting you know the blame and
responsibility on them they're not
hiding for for too many of us it's it's
you right like you're hiding you're not
posting enough content you're not
sharing your story enough you're not
putting yourself out there you're not
creating enough
right and I know I know it's hard and
we'll talk about some of the ideas here
later on in this in this presentation
but
um
if you're not where you want to be yet
it's it's a direct result of your effort
your abilities your skill set your
putting in the work right but I just
wanted to to
highlight in the language and I know
this wasn't Ben's intent I know Ben in
post in it was not saying it's their
fault but just just being careful about
the word choice that we're using and the
stories that we're telling ourselves
because
they're not hiding the problem is not
that your fans are hiding the problem is
that you're hiding and we need to
unleash that and that's that part in the
book that's part of this program it's
part of this presentation
um and so I'm super excited to
help unleash that so I know sharing is
scary
I talk about it in the book
um whenever I say BTS has built to serve
page 108 if you want more references you
can go in and check it out I have this
picture of me and Alex up because we
discovered uh last week or two weeks ago
that Alex has a learning disability
uh
one ADHD which is super common but also
something called executive functioning
anyway and it's been it's been hurting
he's you know had it his whole life just
kind of figured it out now uh he learns
slower than most people things that I
don't have to repeat to others I have to
go over multiple times with him before
he finally gets it and now we're trying
to devise kind of strategies and
techniques and how we can learn more
effectively but what I told them
yesterday and this is why I love this
group is I can share what's happening
right now yesterday was Alex you have to
share that story you have to share that
you have a learning disability you have
to share how that makes you feel you
have to share the impact that is having
on you trying to be an entrepreneur or
trying to build the business trying to
live your life how does it hit you
because other people will connect to
that right and and he he doesn't know
how to process it yet he's worried about
you know judgment and how people see it
uh he you know wants to talk to his mom
first and all this stuff but in sharing
is the thing that will make people
connect to you
and so he's already shared his stories
about
hyperhidrosis and and being the
excessive sweating and um not being able
to talk to girls and all this stuff and
a lot of it is in is in the book but
this just happened you know last week
and yesterday was my conversation with
him about you have to share this with
your audience and that's actually part
of the healing
that is actually part of the healing
because as long as you're worried about
it as long as you're afraid of the
judgment and what people might say about
it you keep it hidden you keep yourself
plain small and then you don't create
any amazing content and that secret owns
you and so I told them great go talk to
your mom awesome but then you have to go
post
he's like we'll try to post it as a
story should I posted his Instagram live
like it doesn't matter just get it out
there
just get it out there so that somebody
watches it and gives you some kind of
comment I mean the comments are all
going to be positive right nobody's
going to come on and say Alex I never
knew you were a dummy right at least I
hope not
but in sharing it and getting the secret
out there it's it's incredibly
empowering and other people will then be
inspired as well to talk to Alex about
their learning disability and be able to
share in their life the things that are
happening so this is part of the hiding
this is part of the hiding that we all
go through is the story that you're
afraid to share is the thing that you
have to share to help people connect to
you it makes sense logically it's just
difficult
it's difficult to share the thing that
you don't want other people to know
it's still hard like Alex has gone
through this Alex has been around me for
five years so he knows this but it's
still hard right so that's fine it's
meant to be hard
but getting it out there becomes the
healing process
in in Bill to serve page 63 we talk
about being the tree and so my my
concept of the tree is
um the tree is designed to breathe in
uh carbon dioxide right which is too
much for a human is poison it eats it it
grows cement and then it spits out
oxygen
for the world and I see that as our job
as thought leaders as movement makers is
your job is partly to eat the negativity
to eat the criticism to eat the judgment
to grow from it and then spit out oxygen
positivity for the world for the people
who currently are who you used to be
and so when I say they're not hiding you
are what I want to see is more
consistency more vulnerability more
personal storytelling more effort and
care right more more more and more and
it may not you may not have great
results yet you may not be proud of the
finished product yet because you're
still learning still getting better
still trying but all of these things the
more you the more you can apply the more
you can become that tree the more you're
sharing your story
you're going to find that the people
your thousand true fans suddenly come
out of air quotes hiding
right they come out of hiding because
you've given them permission to
because for them to come out of hiding
you need to come out of hiding first
does that make sense
uh Joshua saying my favorite
illustration was the tree
yeah I don't know where that came from
um
it was off I was doing some podcast and
uh it was with uh somebody who was into
like psychedelics and and crazy stuff
um and I and I told him that he's a tree
and then I said you know what that's a
great that's a great analogy anyway okay
so I don't know if Ben is here Ben
saying hi if you're here I might have
missed it if you are but um so Ben and
this is not meant to be a knock at Ben
right Ben I went to his Facebook account
and he posted once three days ago and
then one six days ago and and maybe he's
posting somewhere else I couldn't find
his Instagram or anything else but this
is where now
we need to step up right this is part of
the hiding if we're posting two times in
six days if you want to be a thought
leader and and get your message out
there it has to be more frequently right
back to here more consistency more
vulnerability more personal storytelling
more effort and care so if I'm running
Ben's page here I want to I want to see
those things I want to see the
consistency right so six times in six
days right I want to see the
storytelling right here it's just
telling me about a new podcast and what
does it say new podcast with Naomi
awesome uh use a discounted code to get
prices awesome I mean
there's no vulnerability there there's
no storytelling I'm sure the podcast
itself is great but tell me in the
content that you're posting right and so
more care more effort more storytelling
more more vulnerability more consistency
that's how you pull them out of hiding
by you leaning by example
that making sense
and and I love Ben this isn't this again
is not meant to be a knock against Ben
or or any of you guys have just pulled
his profile as an example I bet if I
went into a lot of your profiles would
be something similar and and I want you
to take the accountability and start
creating the content that you need to to
track the people to build your movement
of the impact you want to have
we are live movement makers I'm going to
do something a little different today
I'm excited it's gonna be a little bit
different this is either going to be the
greatest thing of all time or or Flop so
you don't know until you until you try
and you experiment I was looking at the
topics and most of the topics that we've
covered so far have been
uh fairly easy to turn into a slide deck
and then talk about them and answer
questions and give you some context as
we go along the way and I try to inject
some of the new things that I'm working
on through it and I looked at the topics
you know Outreach email nurture list
that's easy to make into a deck how to
help our world have more peace and love
I love that topic you guys didn't vote
that up but but uh so we're not doing
that but that that's that's also
something that can be turned into a deck
the how to make money one though I
thought would have to be better to turn
this into a strategy session with you
guys I mean I cover it in built to serve
right we talk about the three different
things and I'll touch on it quickly uh
but the fact that that's the number one
most voted topic I want to go deeper
with you I want to I want to use this
time together to really understand what
you're trying to work on and how we can
turn your current projects into making
more money for you
um it's it's why I wrote the book is yes
to figure out your purpose but to turn
it into something that you can make into
business and support your your yourself
your family your community all of it
quickly and be able to serve I cover
three different areas and again we can
dive as deep as you want into these the
first one is the fast pass to Freedom
right and so that the idea is you're
creating content on your channel uh all
your social accounts you have your
10-pack of content
I go through it in here we can talk more
in depth if you want but basically that
acts as a as a marketing brochure for
you so that when people hit your social
media accounts they say huh this person
knows what they're talking about they
get me they're like me uh but they're a
little bit further ahead I'd like to
work with this person great it actually
is your marketing brochure then what
you're doing is Outreach right and
you're you're reaching 50 to 100 people
a day dming them message them uh get
involved in relevant conversations uh
offering to help and then they're going
to go to your uh to your page see what
you can do and
set up your first call
that's a lot of grunt work that's a lot
of hand-to-hand combat right there's a
lot of you 50 to 100 times a day
reaching out and damning people most
people won't even see it most people
won't reply but then you get people who
do and that's that's the train to start
building the momentum
um the second path is through
Partnerships and referrals right so you
find the people who can actually move
the needle for you who already have your
target audience and you find a way to
try to start working with them
uh so what Evan just did as an example
on uh in in this post recently where he
said he was doing you know he got on a
call there were people in there he did
his presentation and somebody wanted to
hire him as a result right whoever LED
that call with all those people in it
that's a perfect example of a partner
relationship so you think who already
has my target audience how can I connect
with them to provide value
um and then get in there and start
making a relationship and then the third
strategy is through thought leadership
and that's content and that's ongoing
and that's where I spend a good chunk of
the book because people
uh struggle and people that make good
thought leadership content
um and so guiding through how to make
content Beyond just the first 10 pack of
content
and staying consistent and picking the
platforms and turning your thoughts your
expertise into a lead magnet that that
ongoing keeps bringing in Revenue
attention traffic interest for you I
want to share two quick examples of
people who I've mentored and trained
who've gone through this process
uh from scratch right from zero it's
easy to look at what I'm doing and say
wow
you know you've already had all this
traction you've been on YouTube for 11
years and all this stuff but from
scratch uh two people who I mentored uh
one was Lily and one was Jeremy and Lily
uh wanted to be a speaker and she came
here and said I want to be a speaker I
want to speak on stage and so you know
we quickly got her a tedx speech
um and that was her very very first
speaking gig but then I said hey if you
want to be a great speaker you actually
have to be a great uh one-on-one you
gotta you gotta do coaching whether you
want to be a coach long term or are you
just using that as a platform to become
a better speaker because if you're going
to speak you have to think about it as
not speaking to an audience of a
thousand people or 100 people or 20
people but a hundred individual people a
thousand individual people and what
makes you a better speaker is having
worked one-on-one with so many people
because if you're just given a message
you don't feel how it bounces back when
you're working with somebody and you say
go do this they say yeah but yeah but
yeah but
and that doesn't come out when you're
speaking on stage so if you know what
the Yeah butts are going to be because
you've worked with enough people
uh that turns you into a much better
speaker because you can address it from
stage so I told her to do this and at
the beginning she didn't even know how
to coach people so it also depends what
level of expertise you have coming in
she knew nothing and so I said you know
what take the take the one word
framework my first book your one word
and go off and start helping people
figure out their one word
um she believed in it she you know she
connected with it so that became what
she was doing and she did her first I
want to say 75 to 100 calls for free
absolutely just reaching out people who
are uh following me people who are uh
anybody who commented on any of her
posts
um anybody she was going live every day
and she did 75 to 100 calls for free
absolutely free
just to build momentum just to get the
experience as a coach because she wasn't
very good because she didn't know she
was doing yet now she got a lot better
and then she started charging the first
the indication of you're ready to start
making money is do people ask you hey
can I hire you back if you do a free
session how many people are then saying
can I can I hire you can we go deeper
can can you help me can I learn more
um until you get there then you haven't
done a good enough job it might have
been okay it's great but it wasn't
enough that they say I really love this
person this person can make an impact
and so that's why getting the practice
out even on things like Instagram live
is fantastic practice because it's free
and it's more exposure and showing you
coaching is a great chance to get people
to
uh then say oh can I hire you can I work
with you right every time I go live on
Instagram I get DMS of people saying Hey
how do I hire you how do I work with you
how can I it's like that's not the
business I want to be in but it could be
if if I was starting from zero and I had
a job and was trying to get this thing
off the ground I would do a lot more
coaching and one-on-one work because
that can help pay the bills to get you
to where you need to go so
the first person then said Hey how do I
hire you Lily in uh she said oh my God I
don't even know how to charge for this
so we started off low you know it was 25
bucks an hour for the first 10 people uh
and then once you hit 10 people 25 it
became 50 bucks an hour for the next 10
people and then once you hit 10 people
became 75 bucks an hour for the next 10
people and then 100 bucks an hour for
the next 10 people and and kept scaling
up and scaling up now this is taking a
person who's got a lot of heart a lot of
care a lot of love but no skill set yet
not an expert at what she does and so
it's building that up
uh so it took some time but it was
really just a matter of doing enough
Outreach getting enough calls getting
that practice in that could have been a
lot faster if she was crushing from the
very first call right but she had to put
in the Reps to get better the other one
is Jeremy and Jeremy has helped build
the YouTube Consulting business so
you know he's he's coming up on one year
I think it was July that he started uh
charging money for it and it's six
figure business business in one year
and he
I taught him basically everything about
YouTube he's he's still learning from me
I mean he just messaged me this morning
or just before going live here there's
been a conversation back and forth about
one of his clients and he took all of my
learnings
and started to then reach out to people
to say
hey uh thought leaders especially you've
got this YouTube channel I want to help
I've got three big ideas that can I
think help blow you up uh I'd love to
hop on a call and and help you and help
go through the ideas uh
we started when I got back from my tour
last year and
I said okay dude you got to do you know
five calls for free
just to see just to see how much you
picked up I gave them homework go
research go learn go watch these
channels go digest everything I've ever
said about YouTube and he did he did the
homework he came back and the call was
actually the first call we did was way
better than I thought it was going to be
because before
you know I put my name on something I
want to make sure that it's going to be
high quality going up not saying hey you
know we've helped Evan Carmichael build
his channel uh we're gonna use yours his
strategies and apply it to yours got to
make sure that it's actually you know
he's represented a brand well
um so it's been all Outreach
um I I haven't been on a single sales
call with him I helped him land
maybe maybe two two of his deals
um now he's using my name to go off and
get deals but it's mostly just Outreach
and it's him on the call on me giving a
little bit of mentorship behind the
scenes uh and you know 100 100K Plus in
the first year
um that's great service based business
and so
it really just depends it's definitely a
volume give getting out there this is if
you're selling coaching or Consulting
Services uh and it depends on how good
you are you know Jeremy was really good
and had a leg up because I was I was
teaching him and mentoring him
but I took a guy who was Jeremy was when
I got him a grocery store clerk
he was stocking shelves at a grocery
store and I just saw something and then
said hey I want to start a YouTube
Consulting business with you you have to
go off and learn all this stuff and um
he said yes and so far it's worked out
great and he's keeping the up up the
level of clients right so his first
client was 500 bucks a month and then it
became a thousand and then 2 000 and now
it was up to three and a half thousand
or thirty six hundred something like
that a month for some of his clients
and it's awesome and so that that's
what's possible taking somebody from a
grocery store clerk who knows nothing
about the stuff to quickly learning and
going off lending deals and getting
clients if you want to watch the full
version of this video as well as train
live with me twice a month to help you
build your movement and be around some
other amazing people just like you check
out my movement makers program the link
to join is right there next to me can't
wait to see you there continue to
believe and go join